Sean Spicer is at least the second Trump
staffer to completely invent and concoct
an imaginary terrorist attack completely
out of thin air you'll remember a trump
advisor Kellyanne conned me as I now
refer to her she was interviewed on
MSNBC by Chris Matthews and she cited
the non-existent Bowling Green massacre
as an example of a terrorist attack
committed by refugees which of course
justified the need for Trump's Muslim
majority country immigration ban here is
a reminder of Kellyanne conned me citing
this non-existent terrorist attack but
it's brand-new information to people
that President Obama had a six-month ban
on the Iraqi refugee program after two
Iraqis came here to this country were
radicalized and never the master
masterminds behind the bowling-green
massacre covered yeah unfortunately as
the word imaginary suggests there was no
such massacre there was no Bowling Green
Massacre but it is not just Kellyanne
conned me it is also Sean Spicer Trump's
press secretary doing the exact same
thing he has repeatedly now pointed to
Atlanta Atlanta as a city that was
attacked by some kind of foreign
terrorists in order to justify the
muslim-majority country immigration ban
now let me be super clear there has
never been a refugee immigrant or
whatever Islamist terror attack in
Atlanta nor one perpetrated by any
refugees from individuals on Donald
Trump's list here is Sean Spicer in an
appearance on ABC's this week talking
about again Atlanta I know that in some
cases are gonna be a bit of an
inconvenience but the inconvenience
there is a humiliation no there's a
hundred and nine people that were slowed
down over 325,000 foreign visitors that
came in but what what are we say to the
family that that loses somebody of a
terrorist to whether it's Atlanta or San
Bernardino or the Boston bomber those
people each of whom had gone out to a
country and then quit what Atlanta and
then again on MSNBC's Morning Joe Sean
Spicer talking about Atlanta saying
quote to many of these cases that have
happened whether you're talking
about San Bernardino Atlanta they've
happened Boston and then again at the
White House press briefing later the
same day that he was on Morning Joe
Spicer pointed to Atlanta as a need for
quote extreme vetting saying quote I
don't think you have to look any further
than the families of the Boston Marathon
in Atlanta in San Bernardino to ask if
we can go further there's obviously
steps that we can and should be taking
and I think the president is going to
continue to do what he can to make sure
that this country is as safe as possible
there has not been a jihadist terror
attack in Atlanta period it's fake now
here Pat is what's more fascinating when
you want to talk about under covered and
over covered incidents of terror there
was an incident in Atlanta in 1996 a
pipe bomb exploded at the Centennial
Olympic Park during the Atlanta Olympic
Games the terrorist was an american-born
white dude from Florida named Eric
Robert Rudolph please please please
don't forget what information warfare
expert Molly McHugh told us yesterday
this is gas lighting it's it's
disinformation now whether it's on
purpose or not you're planting these
seeds in people's minds and we know that
the low information trump voters are
very malleable they are now going to say
yeah yeah yeah San Bernardino Boston
Atlanta there were lots of these attacks
and just look at those other two
examples Boston and San Bernardino in
Boston the attackers were from Chechnya
which is part of Russia right in San
Bernardino one of the attackers was a US
citizen and they were of Pakistani
descent so neither one of those
countries are on that seven list ban you
know yeah couldn't have said it better
myself
also another really really good point
which is even the one the other ones
that Sean Spicer is listing actually
would not have been impacted by Trump's
list at all widely known Russian
propaganda technique which is make
people question what can they believe I
mean Sean Spicer listed all that stuff
and Kellyanne conned me listed that the
Bowling Green massacre yeah I mean I
guess we need the immigration ban
San Bernardino in Boston being real but
not good examples of attacks that would
have been prevented by Trump's ban
Atlanta completely fake but in the minds
of the trumpets they will remember what
they'll remember oh yeah
Sean Spicer listed all that stuff and
Kellyanne conk me also had one discuss
this on our reddit discussion forum join
us david pakman.com slash read it re d
di t Gamefly is sort of like netflix for
video games they have over 8,000 new and
classic games for xbox one xbox 360 ps4
ps3 Wii and a bunch of other platforms
and you can play as many games as you
want for one monthly fee and if you find
some games you want to keep you can buy
them for a low used price there's never
any due dates or late fees and our
audience can get a free 30 day trial at
Gamefly offer.com slash TDP s the games
are shipped directly to you with return
envelopes included there's no contracts
and you can rent games through the
mobile app get the free 30 day trial for
the David Pakman show audience and
support our show by going to Gamefly
offer.com slash TDP s